>>> YOU'VE GOT TO LISTEN TO
THIS.
IT'S OKAY TO BE A UNICORN.
OR IS IT?
A SCHOOL DISTRICT JUST OUTSIDE
COLUMBUS, OHIO ASKING A GUEST
AUTHOR EARLIER THIS MONTH NOT TO
READ HIS BOOK ABOUT BEING
DIFFERENT TO ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
STUDENTS.
IT IS THE LATEST EXAMPLE OF
BOOKS BECOMING CONTROVERSIAL IN
SCHOOLS WITHOUT ANY CREDIBLE
REASON, AND IT'S CERTAINLY NOT
THE LAST, INCLUDING IN FLORIDA
WHERE MATH TEXTBOOKS ARE BEING
REMOVED FROM THE CURRICULUM
BECAUSE OF ALLEGED REFERENCES --
ALLEGED -- REFERENCES TO
CRITICAL RACE THEORY.
SERIOUSLY.
IN MATH BOOKS.
OKAY.
MATH TEXTBOOKS.
JASON THORPE IS THE AUTHOR OF
"IT'S OKAY TO BE A UNICORN".
HE JOINS ALSO WITH US SENIOR
COMMENTATOR BAKARI SELLERS.
JASON, I WANT TO START WITH YOUR
EXPERIENCE.
YOU WERE ABLE TO GO TO THE
SCHOOL IN THE BUCKEYE VALLEY
DISTRICT, BUT YOU WEREN'T ABLE
TO TALK ABOUT OR READ "IT'S OKAY
TO BE A UNICORN."
WHY NOT?
>> I WAS TOLD THE DAY BEFORE THE
VISIT THAT THE PRINCIPAL WAS NOT
GOING TO HAVE THAT CONVERSATION
WITH ME.
THEY THOUGHT THAT IT WAS NOT TO
BE ON THE AGENDA.
THERE WAS ONE PARENT WHO WAS
CONCERNED ABOUT DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT THE UNICORN BECAUSE THEY
THOUGHT IT WAS A BOOK TO TELL
CHILDREN TO BE GAY.
>> SOME PARENTS THOUGHT IT WAS A
BOOK TO RECRUIT CHILDREN TO BE
GAY?
>> ONE PARENT DID.
>> TO BE CLEAR, SO EVERYONE ELSE
KNOWS, WHAT EXACTLY IS YOUR BOOK
ABOUT?
>> IT'S ACTUALLY A STORY I LIKED
GROWING UP IN A SMALL TOWN WHERE
I WOULD SHARE MY DREAMS, AND
THEN YOU FEEL INSECURE, SO I
FELT I NEEDED TO TELL THE STORY
FROM A POINT OF VIEW THAT
CHILDREN CAN UNDERSTAND.
IT WAS A HORSE LIVING IN A
UNICORN KENNEL.
SOMEONE PUTS ON BEAUTIFUL HORNS
AND HE IS CHOSEN TO BE THE
HONORARY UNICORN, AND HE THOUGHT
HE WOULD REVEAL THAT HE'S NOT A
UNICORN.
THEN HE THOUGHT WHAT IF MY
FRIENDS DON'T LIKE ME, WHAT IF
THIS, WHAT IF THAT?
THEN YOU REALIZE HE DOESN'T CARE
ABOUT WHAT THEY THINK, AND FOR
THE FIRST TIME HE REALLY FELT
GOOD ABOUT BEING WHO HE WAS.
>> THIS IS WHAT THE BUCKEYE
VALLEY SUPERINTENDENT SAYS.
HE SAID, UNFORTUNATELY, BEFORE
WE WERE ABLE TO GATHER ALL THE
FACTS, THERE WAS A
MISCOMMUNICATION THAT LED TO THE
ALTERING OF THE ORIGINAL PLAN.
ALTHOUGH THE STUDENTS WERE STILL
ABLE TO ENJOY THE EVENT, I
REGRET THAT THINGS PLAYED OUT
THE WAY IT DID WHICH MAY HAVE
LED TO MISUNDERSTANDINGS.
THE DISTRICT SAYS THERE WERE
SOME PARENTAL CONCERNS HERE.
ARE PARENTS DOING THE WORK TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT EXACTLY IS BEING
TAUGHT, JASON?
>> WELL, YEAH, WHAT'S
INTERESTING IS I LIVE 12 MILES
FROM THE SCHOOL.
I WOULD HAVE BROUGHT SOME
SKETCHES AND WE WOULD HAVE
DISCUSSED ALL OF THIS.
WE HAD BULK SALES OF THIS BOOK
AS PARENTS IN THIS SCHOOL
ORDERED ABOUT 500 COPIES, BUT
THEY WORRIED A LOT ABOUT THE
UNICORN BOOK.
SO, YEAH, THEY HAD ALL THE
MATERIALS SIX TO EIGHT WEEKS
BEFORE I GOT THERE, AND IT WAS
THE DAY BEFORE WHEN ALL THIS
HAPPENED.
I DIDN'T GET INQUIRIES ABOUT
ANYTHING FROM THE PARENTS, MORE
THE OPPOSITE OF HOW EXCITED THEY
WERE THAT I WAS COMING.
>> BAKARI, YOU'VE BEEN SITTING
BY PATIENTLY WAITING.
I CAN'T WAIT TO HEAR YOU WEIGH
IN ON THIS.
WHAT HAPPENED TO JASON IS REALLY
JUST A MICROCOSM OF WHAT'S
HAPPENING ACROSS THE COUNTRY
FLIGHT, CORRECT?
>> YEAH.
I THINK WHAT WE HAVE TO DO IS A
FEW THINGS.
ONE, REALIZE IT'S OKAY TO BE
GAY.
TWO, IT'S OKAY TO BE A UNICORN.
THREE, GO OUT AND BUY JASON'S
BOOK SO MORE YOUNG PEOPLE HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO FEEL GOOD
ABOUT THEMSELVES.
BUT WHAT WE'RE SEEING IS THIS
WAVE OF ANTI-INTELLECTUALISM
SWEEP ACROSS COUNTRY.
YOU SEE THESE REPUBLICAN
GOVERNORS WHO DON'T WANT PEOPLE
TO FEEL COMFORTABLE IN THEIR OWN
SKIN, WHO DON'T WANT PEOPLE TO
LEARN ABOUT THEIR HISTORY, WHO
ARE AFRAID OF FREEDOM AND GROWTH
IN YOUNG PEOPLE.
IT'S OKAY TO BE A UNICORN.
THIS IS BAD ENGLISH, I KNOW, BUT
I TELL HERSHEY'S THE MOST
BEAUTIFULEST PRINCESS MERMAID IN
THE ENTIRE WORLD.
YES, IT'S OKAY TO BE A PRINCESS,
IT'S OKAY TO BE A MERMAID AND
IT'S OKAY TO BE A UNICORN.
>> WOW.
DID YOU EVER WATCH "WIZARD OF
OZ"?
>> I DON'T KNOW WHY PEOPLE ARE
SO SCARED OF GAY FOLK, DON.
MAYBE THAT'S THE QUESTION.
THAT'S WHAT I DON'T GET.
I DON'T KNOW WHY PEOPLE ARE SO
SCARED OF GAY FOLKS IN THE
SOUTH.
>> IT'S THE MAGIC.
PEOPLE ARE AFRAID OF THE MAGIC.
YOU WOULDN'T HAVE THE MAGIC
KINGDOM WITHOUT GAY PEOPLE.
YOU WOULDN'T HAVE THE MAGIC OF
JUST ABOUT EVERYTHING.
BUT HEY, THAT'S A WHOLE OTHER
STORY.
DID YOU WANT TO SAY ANYTHING,
JASON?
>> IT'S AMAZING TO ME, IT SEEMS
LIKE PEOPLE HAVE FORGOTTEN WHAT
IT WAS LIKE TO BE A KID.
FOR ME I'M WRITING THESE BOOKS
BECAUSE I'M WRITING TO THAT ONE
KID WHO FEELS ALONE, BAD,
CONFUSED.
I WRITE THIS BECAUSE I LOVE THAT
WE ARE DIFFERENT.
IT'S JUST AMAZING THAT WE WOULD
WANT TO TAKE THIS OUTLET AWAY
FROM OUR CHILDREN, BECAUSE BOOKS
ENTERTAINED ME AS A KID.
THIS MAY REACH THAT ONE KID, AND
IT SEEMS SO GREAT BECAUSE YOU
DON'T KNOW WHAT BOOK WILL AFFECT
WHAT KID IN WHAT WAY.
IT'S REALLY SAD.
>> I WAS JUST, LIKE, GLANCING
DOWN AT SOME OF THESE NUMBERS,
BECAUSE YOU MENTIONED FLORIDA,
BAKARI.
IN FLORIDA, THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS REJECTED MORE THAN
50 MATH BOOKS NEXT YEAR, 60% IN
GRADES K THROUGH 5, SOME OF THEM
WILL REFERENCE TO CRITICAL RACE
THEORY.
CRITICAL RACE THEORY IS NOT IN
THE CURRICULUM, AND THE IDEA
THAT IT'S IN MATH TEXTBOOKS,
SERIOUSLY?
>> WAIT UNTIL THEY FIND OUT SOME
MATH IS NOT BINARY, RIGHT?
BUT, I MEAN, IT MAKES YOU LAUGH
ABOUT IT IF IT WASN'T SO SAD.
I'M NOT QUITE SURE WHAT EXACTLY
WE'RE DOING.
IF YOU WANT TO BRING IT BACK TO
THE 50,000-FOOT VIEW, IT'S
PUTINESQUE, IT'S
AUTHORITARIANISM.
IT'S SHOWING WHAT WE DON'T WANT
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA TO
BE.
THIS IS THE PROVERBIAL BOOK
BURNING MINUS THE SMOKE AND
FLAMES.
IN SCHOOL THERE SHOULD BE A
PLACE.
I'M NOT FOR CANCEL CULTURE ON
EITHER SIDE.
I THINK IF YOU WANT TO BRING
SOMEBODY WHO IS A RIGHT WING NUT
TO THE CAMPUS, YOU SHOULD BE
ABLE TO DO THAT.
I THINK IF YOU WANT TO EDUCATE
PEOPLE OR WHATEVER, YOU SHOULD
BE ABLE TO DO THAT.
SCHOOLS SHOULD BE A PLACE WHERE
YOU HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN
AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE ABOUT WHAT
THE WORLD IS AND WHAT IT SHOULD
BE OR COULD BE.
WHAT WE'RE DOING RIGHT NOW IS
JUST STIFLING THEM IN WHAT WE
BELIEVE AMERICA IS, AND
UNFORTUNATELY, I DON'T THINK
AMERICA FITS THE MOLD FOR ANY OF
US ON THIS PLANET.
>> LOOK, I'M GOING TO DISAGREE
WITH YOU ON THAT.
I DON'T THINK A RIGHT WING NUT
JOB, AND I WOULDN'T WANT TO TALK
ABOUT THEM TO MY KIDS.
I HAVE TO RUN, THOUGH.
THIS IS NOT THE END OF THIS
CONVERSATION.
JASON, BEST OF LUCK TO YOU.
"IT'S OKAY TO BE A UNICORN."
WE ALWAYS TALKED ABOUT ME BEING
A UNICORN, BUT THAT'S BECAUSE
I'M THE ONLY BLACK PERSON IN